buck sexton remembers very well he's the
co-host of the clay travis and buck
sexton show he joins us tonight buck
sexton thanks so much for coming on so
when you watch cnn and they tell you
that because
a supreme court justice samolito wrote
an opinion that the right likes that the
threat of violence comes from the right
what's your first reaction to that
the democrat party is wallowing in its
delusions at this point doesn't know how
to get out of them quite honestly i mean
the notion that there might be
right-wing violence in response to a
decision that the right overwhelmingly
likes makes absolutely no sense and
beyond that let's think about who we're
really talking about here with the
pro-life movement those aren't tiny
molotov cocktails they're holding when
they hold vigils they're candles i mean
these are people who overwhelmingly in
the pro-life movement want to protect
life and protect people and are orderly
but the democrat party has never
actually had a reckoning with the fact
that there was a long-standing
insurrection in the year 2020 and it was
blm and antifa and it was egged on by
people in the press there was mass
looting and mass hysteria in cities
across the country they've never even
had a moment of introspection about this
and now they want to lecture us about
lawlessness in the aftermath of a
decision that actually goes against them
but tucker if you're willing to believe
that there's a right to abortion in the
constitution you are willing to believe
absolutely anything and that's where the
left is right now
but but it's like this with everything i
mean this is the way they communicated
and it seems to me that people who are
not passive aggressive miss it every
time
they say things like you're violent as
they burn your cities as you just
pointed out we're not letting your kids
into college because of their skin color
and you're a racist
everything is like this i can't remember
an issue on which liberals flatly
declared their intent and then backed it
up with evidence
well in this case i think that there's
some degree of political insurance that
they're trying to put forward here by
making it seem like well if things do
get really ugly and tucker i think they
probably will i mean hopefully that
won't happen but with riots and protests
they'll make it seem like well they're
provocateurs on both sides of this
because i do think that people have
started to figure out more and more as
the miracle of the unifying biden
presidency and the adults in charge
hasn't really uh taken the way that they
promised that the democrats the left
they are the riot party this is what
they do they are the mob they're the
ones that freak out when they don't get
their way throw childish tantrums they
don't petition the court they threaten
to or try to burn down the court we all
see it and so by trying to muddy the
waters they make themselves feel better
about some of the hysteria that you've
already shown and god forbid something
really bad does happen they'll say well
it was because of rising temperatures
across the board yeah rising
temperatures from the uh democrat antifa
lunatics trying to burn things down
it's just so bad for every i mean
leaving aside the issue wherever you
stand on abortion it is not good for
people to threaten supreme court
justices it's not good to spray paint
churches or intimidate people
out of going to services on sunday
people are intimidated about going to
church this coming sunday why doesn't
the white house just say you know don't
do that the the
lack of willingness i mean this was
honestly a little stunning i watched
those press conferences a lot with jen
saki i watch what they say in this white
house the fact that they wouldn't take
one moment to establish the most basic
principle that our supreme court
justices our supreme court their safety
is inviolate and we have that is
nonpartisan this oh tensions are really
high don't say something like that when
tensions are rising on the left and
among democrats but gensake doesn't want
to upset the democrat base who are
enraged and who are effectively melting
down before her very eyes and so she
won't say what's so obvious so clear
which is if you have any principles
about sacred democracy and our
institutions you don't you lay off the
supreme court you don't actually
threaten people you don't put up their
addresses
but they are the power they are the
party of the mob and i don't think
they're going to be able to turn that
off anytime soon so there's real reason
for concern unfortunately yeah it seems
dangerous for sure buck sexton i
appreciate thank you